je compte maintenant le plus célèbre
tableau sans aucun doute de léonard de
vinci exposée au louvre inquiète en
effet son état de santé
c'est à dire son état de conservation
pose problème car le sourire le plus
énigmatique du monde n'a pas été peint
sur une toile mais une mince panneaux de
bois de peuplier qui a tendance en ce
moment à se déformer pour cause
d'humidité isabelle bechler marie-hélène
bonne un sourire vieux de 500 ans pour
lequel des millions de visiteurs ont
littéralement traversé le monde ce que
les photographes ne voit pas à l'abri de
la lourde barrière de verre qui protège
mona lisa c'est que le panneau de
peuplier contre lequel elle est peinte
se gondole de manière inquiétante
le musée du louvre s'apprête à lancer
une étude préliminaire au lifting ou à
la consolidation de cette oeuvre qu'on
connaît finalement mal tellement et les
mythiques que le panneau et jouer un peu
au bout de cinq siècles c'est tout à
fait normal donc les mesures que le
musée du loup va prendre son sont sont
certainement nécessaires mais je conte
certainement efficace mais il n'empêche
que la peinture à l'huile est un métier
qui du fait de l'utilisation de l'huile
et des vernis vieillit plus que la
peinture à l'eau et c'est donc un
tableau qui probablement souffre du
vieillissement de l'huile et des vernis
voici le point de vue d'un peintre qui a
copié l'oeuvre avec la distance de
l'humour mais l'intimité que cela
suppose aussi à la chaux faire d'abord
elle a été volée elle a été découpée et
transporte en italie revenu quand elle
est venue
agité par françois 1er a clos lucé elle
a voyagé roulait donc elle est là elle a
voyagé la joconde est là d'expérience
mais enfin ça l'uac santé accentuer son
vieillissant ce sourire qui a donc
beaucoup souffert malgré les apparences
ne peut décemment être soustraits à
l'adoration des visiteurs pendant plus
de 48 heures or mona lisa sera l'année
prochaine installé dans une salle
entièrement rénovée et éventuellement
restaurer à la faveur de cet
embellissement
c'est tout le dilemme du louvre dans la
joconde est très prosaïquement le fonds
de commerce